well good afternoon welcome and this one
more lovely new haven day welcome to the
Whitney and Betty macmillan Center for
International and area studies I'm
Charlie Hill I've been teaching here for
a long time and once was in the American
foreign service where I watched our
honored guests at work so I'm filling in
for in Shapiro who is now teaching a
class and Ian as I'm sure most of you
know is a sterling professor of
political science and the director of
the henry r lewis center where we are
right now and Ian will be joining us Oh
whenever his students will untie him and
let him go today we are welcoming
Senator Richard Lugar as this year's
George Herbert Walker junior lecturer
the Honorable George Herbert Walker
third Yale class of 53 our former
ambassador to Hungary established this
lectureship in memory of his father yale
college class of 1927 and ambassador
Walker and his family members are with
us today we want to welcome them the
Walker lecture is really the signature
lecture the signature intellectual of
event of the Macmillan Center and this
such for 2014 and has I've been at these
lectures for a long time going back to
Madeleine Albright when she was here
speaking as when she was ambassador to
the United Nations Richard Holbrooke has
been here secretary-general of the
United Nations Ban ki-moon has been here
it's a very distinguished collection of
major figures that have spoken here
Senator Richard Lugar is a
fifth-generation Hoosier long list serve
member of Congress in Indiana history he
is one of those guys who graduated first
in his class everywhere probably in
kindergarten in high school at denison
university then was a Rhodes Scholar at
Pembroke College Oxford he holds what
must be getting close to the
n-c-double-a record of 46 honorary
degrees from colleges and universities
in 15 states he's also United States
Navy veteran he volunteered in 1957 and
served as an intelligence officer for
the Chief of Naval Operations then
Admiral arleigh Burke after a
distinguished and the record will show a
very innovative career in state and
local government Richard Lugar became a
senator and has produced a record I
think almost unmatched in American
history of bipartisan achievement ship
he really has won national and
international distinction for the idea
of working across the aisle and in the
context of today's Washington he
certainly stands as a paragon of what
senatorial bipartisanship can really
accomplish he has been a major figure in
the reduction of nuclear chemical and
biological weapons he forged the famous
bipartisan arrangement with Senate Armed
Services Chairman Sam Nunn of Georgia
and to date the nunn-lugar program has
deactivated more than 7,600 nuclear
warheads that at one point were aimed at
the United States beyond foreign affairs
as chairman of the agricultural
committee he built bipartisan support
for federal farm program reforms which
ended the production controls of the 19
30 s increased farm exports raised net
farm income and he's also put forward
initiatives to streamline the Department
of Agriculture reform the food stamp
program preserve the school lunch
program the federal school lunch program
and today he is president of the lugar
Center an organization nonprofit
organization focusing on nuclear
non-proliferation and food security and
he is I understand in the process of
creating the lugar Academy at the
University of Indianapolis which will
like students of Indiana and the region
to Washington policymakers and he is a
professor and distinguished scholar at
the new international school of global
and international affairs at Indiana
University so it's quite quite a record
senator lugar topic today will be modern
American foreign policy in an uncertain
world so please welcome senator Liu
Charles thank you so much for your
thoughtfulness as well as for your great
academic career what a non ER it is to
be in a millon Center to be the friend
and the lecture tonight for mr. Burk
Walker to be with each of you on this
great campus I want to take the
opportunity tonight really Tim I give a
foreign policy talk which I think will
be somewhat different but hopefully
entertaining and enlightening and will
stimulate some of your questions that
will come of East at the end of my
prepared remarks let me just say it at
the outset I saw an interesting column
today by David Brooks in the New York
Times David Brooks writing about the
frustration that so many Americans have
with American leadership was helping
young people to define how they might
enter into more effective leadership one
of the things he suggested was that at
some point fairly abruptly they go
abroad they leave America they take a
look at this country from an entirely
different perspective the rest of the
how the world looks at it and then they
come back and at least see America and a
different light hopefully and one that
inspires them to take chances to enter
politics to become involved really in
public life it was an exciting column
and I mention it because I'm indebted to
Charles for his introduction of some of
the things that I've been involved in
but they really started with the thought
after i graduated from dennis and i had
never been abroad had the opportunity
through the rhodes scholarship to go to
Oxford went over on the boat with the 31
other Rhodes Scholars went
pembroke college only American in the
place managed to get the porter to let
me in that night with my baggage and it
was a revolution in my mind I began to
see how big the world was how many
talented people there are how many
dangers as well as possibilities there
were people there on that campus not
only from the British Isles but from all
over Europe from Russia from the African
states a number of young people really
emerging who were going to play
significant roles really in so-called
underdeveloped countries it led me
really to travels that I had never
contemplated before and also to go to
the American Embassy in London toward
the end of my two-year tenure at Oxford
and volunteer for service United States
Navy because I was convinced really that
I had not only an obligation to my
country but like why isn't this was
likely to be once again sort of a
revolutionary experience and indeed it
was I had no idea that Admiral arleigh
Burke chief Naval Operations was trying
to set up a briefing theater and the
e-ring of the Pentagon where the
so-called Navy point of view will be
presented his rival Curtis LeMay of the
Air Force he felt was getting too much
attention and so he plucked out of
obscurity young in's and moving on to jg
to be one of the intelligence briefers
my responsibility to come in at midnight
every night read the secrets of secrets
of the country ultimately by six-thirty
the other Admirals one of my notes
because arleigh Burke had sometimes a
tendency to send carriers the other way
around the Cape of Good Hope or some
radical move of that ratty and they want
to be prepared for this it was an
awesome experience because i was sent
then to see allen dulles at the CIA to
go to the NSA a vast stage of its
development on occasion even to the
White House where I never saw President
Eisenhower face-to-face but was in a
briefing theater that
vr had used with all the graphics and so
forth very heady business for a young
guy I came back to Indianapolis to save
the family farm and our family
manufacturing business but after a while
we managed to save that and and became
involved in politics in Indianapolis and
to make a long story short richard nixon
made his first trip outside of
Washington to Indianapolis John Lindsay
had gone Democrat I was the last
Republican mayor of a large city and
Nixon was not keen on going out into the
country Vietnam protesters and others
were giving him fits but he did come he
brought a lot of a cabinet with him he
was in palpably relieved after the
ceremonies out front of the city-county
building with sharpshooters all around
and so forth and said lucre I want you
and Mona had to go to Brussels represent
the United States at a conference on
cities they're going to do I happily
accepted that responsibility as the
young mayor of Indianapolis went with
Pat Monahan Oh became a very dear friend
the rest of our lives together and I've
asked had the temerity all the mayors of
the world to come to Indianapolis the
next year for a international conference
on cities well this was startling for my
constituents as well as the mayor's but
50 or 60 came plane loads of people from
Europe from Asia from South America and
so forth they revived of the various
ethnic groups in Indianapolis who had
not seen anybody from the various states
of Yugoslavia or elsewhere for four
years and likewise sort of set the city
on to a course of thinking
internationally the fact that if we were
going to prosper we would need to have
not only exchange students coming and
going but business people coming and
going of people in public life coming
and going from an interior Midwest state
I mentioned all of this because by the
time I got to the Senate I was well
prepared for what I hope would be the
case membership on the Foreign Relations
Committee and this
a period of over three decades a very
exciting experiences year by year almost
week by week all over the world I
started in this way because I am hopeful
as I visit with young people and we're
bringing some Washington to be interns
in our office but more often we're on
college campuses to say that this is the
excitement of living in this world today
the the ability really to see the
possibilities but to do it firsthand
really on foot very modest experiences
for building to a point where you could
make a difference all mentioned has been
made of the significant program that
senator sam nunn of georgia he certainly
had some important ideas at a crucial
time in American history I was very
delighted to be his bipartisan partner
it was an improbable situation that we
would ever meet around a table which
I've rolled down to my Luger center now
with Russians who came to us at the
breakup of the Soviet Union these were
people that we had met for five years
starting with disarmament conferences in
Geneva Switzerland so we we had not
sturdy friendship but we had a trust in
each other and the Russians actually
said to us we are bankrupt we are
breaking down any possibilities of
security around the nuclear weapons that
are aimed at you and you better be
conscious of that because if we can't
control that who knows really what might
happen no accidents during the so-called
period of mutually assured destruction
which for 40 years we all went through
and maybe took for granted but couldn't
be taken for granted them and said what
do you want and they said we want your
money we want a lot of it as a matter of
fact we need your technicians to begin
to pull all this stuff apart we may not
even need some of your troops by the
time we're done and so that was the
beginning of an onlooker qua free threat
reduction program which became
at least a focus for me for the next 20
years year in and year out with the
appropriations necessary to get the
money to do the things with travels all
over Russia the first trip that
President Obama took was during his
first year in the Senate when he came to
me and said deke I know you go to Russia
every year I want to go with you and
Barack and I went to Russia were
detained in quotes in perm a very
strange situation which they felt I
think that I was a spy and our plane was
a spy plane and we were being defended
by the Ravens and so forth this was at
least a time in which I had a chance to
continue to size up the world and some
of the more of dangerous places each
year now this leads me to try to
formulate an idea about foreign policy
night which maybe is a little bit
different sometimes we talk in terms of
our own economy and this has been
especially true in recent weeks about
the large balance sheet the Federal
Reserve Board has been building up and
whether it should be tapered with the
idea that somehow fewer government bonds
are going to be purchased by the Fed
each month very controversial situation
but nevertheless one in which most of
the public now when they hear balance
she thinks of the Federal Reserve Board
and how big it is and without knowing
exactly what this means but let's take a
look at the balance sheet of the United
States tonight with regards of foreign
policy I would start by saying that
essentially the United States has by far
the largest military budget of any
country in the world that has been true
for many years it's needed to provide at
least the pay not only for current
active personnel but likewise for
veterans for all the development of arms
as well as the maintenance of the ones
that we have for all of the troops that
we have a broad who are at war or trying
to maintain the peace as the case may be
we have as
of that balance sheets of ships that
patrol the high seas the only country in
the world literally can send ships
everywhere and we do send ships
everywhere during our so-called new
pivot strategy in Asia we are sending
many more aircraft carriers at other
warships into the South China Sea and
around the Philippines and elsewhere
this is not a well-publicized situation
even the Senate to my knowledge never
been very well briefed on all the
nuances of the pivots I went out to
Hawaii to talk to the Pacific Command
and then to Philippines Thailand and
don't even get some sense of all of this
went on board the USS George Washington
and the Manila Harbor and saw what a
huge aircraft carrier that is the
implications of all of that as it
cruises around for six months for they
take six months of leave we are the
country that keeps the sea lanes open
for foreign trade the possibilities that
there would be more foreign trade it
would be more liberal policies are
impossible really without this force but
is it see in the case of the United
States fleet we have troops that have
been now in Europe in the tens of
thousands ever since World War two ditto
in Asia ever since World War two we have
recently sent a few hundred more troops
to Australia as a part of the pivot for
example in essence these are forces that
have been on the ground they make a huge
difference in terms of not only our
power but the strength of the NATO
alliance for example if we've been
talking about the history of American
foreign policy we be talking about wars
in Europe back and forth for centuries
and hero now we have the NATO
organization which is now we held
together even though countries we
believed you not provide enough money in
their defense budgets they have sent
volunteers to Afghanistan simply to be
by our side
and we take seriously the problems of
countries that are close to the farmer
Soviet Union now to Russia article 5 has
held and as a matter of fact when we
were attacked on 911 all of the
countries of NATO invoked article 5 and
said we're coming to your aid they're
very important development in Asia a
much smaller devotion there
internationally but but recently with
sita organization with a PEC with others
we have become much more active much
their desire much friendlier relations
as a matter of fact i found its time
around in japan in the philippines in
indonesia in particular thailand not
ambivalent but a difficult role between
China and the United States and as they
try to play it down the center and as I
learned from their ambassador to the
lunch not too long ago they have their
own political problems which you read
about daily in the paper I would just
say that we have in addition to all of
that more nuclear weapons still than any
other country in the world Russia a
fairly comparable number we have both
decided as a matter of our own security
as well as the security of the world
that the reduction of these weapons
through successive treaties was very
very important the last one being the
New START treaty which brings down
ideally the number of warheads of both
sides less than 1,800 possibly it'll
turn out to be less than 1500 that there
were still smaller nuclear weapons
theater size and so forth lots of other
problems of that sword but this is a
very big difference from a time which it
was reported informally at least that
both of us had well over 10,000 warheads
aimed at each other it's an interesting
fact in my life as I look back on it but
all the time I was mayor of Indianapolis
it never occurred to me that there might
be one or more of those warheads aimed
at my home city that I was attempting to
serve and
that turn things around it was a shock
when I was out in Siberia one time we
had seen missiles come out of silos I
went down into one of these silos 13th
floor and there were other of the desk
there where essentially the guards had
stood the duty and on the walls all
around were pictures beautiful pictures
of American cities I was the guards
believed were the targets of the ten
warheads on this one missile the
multiple delivery situation this led me
to you know find out was Indianapolis
ever targeted you bet it was so with
every large city in the United States
and just in every military installation
we're talking about mutually assured
destruction this was not simply a phrase
crafted by somebody for some rhetoric it
was deliberate design on the part of
both of our countries to target about
everything in sight in terms of military
or population that would annihilate the
other now somehow we got through this
period of time ignorant as I was as
mayor of Indianapolis that I might see
the whole thing blown up while I was
there we're beyond that point thank
goodness but not home free and I
mentioned this because there is always
trouble as you discuss this new start
treaty or any other treaty and which
some members of the Congress and the
public still take the position but we
should have had all along was a
comprehensive missile defense system
that in essence you don't worry about
arms control and you don't worry about
destruction of these missiles you just
simply set up something so that if
somebody shoots at you it's just shot
down well a long time ago Ronald Reagan
decided this was bogus and we got off of
that book we still have some members of
Congress that are on that hook and they
want to keep every one of our weapons a
matter of fact want to spend seven or
eight billion dollars refurbishing all
of them sometime this is pro
look you'll politics out of oak ridge or
out of New Mexico or so forth but these
are still serious debates as a part of
this balance sheet of having the most
nuclear weapons i would say in addition
to that that we have the ability in this
country to produce not only food for our
population but for some time we have
been able to produce food to try to feed
a great number of people throughout the
world this many people point out usually
are not glibly but this is the part of
their presentation is real problem if we
have eight billion people in the world
and now people say well by 2050 probably
nine billion often 800 840 million
people are mentioned each day as chronic
challenge in terms of food to the point
of being close to starvation at any one
point so this is a huge problem
worldwide with the United States with
our food production situation and I
don't want to get into an entirely
different argument today by mentioning
that I'm a strong proponent of
genetically modified seed because we use
this on our farm when my dad was getting
50 bushels to the acre as I was a boy
pulling volunteer corn out of the
soybean field I like to relate now that
we've got 191 bushels on our farm this
year of corn per acre we have two in the
same land same number of acres we've got
to do this really all over the world if
we're going to make a difference it's
huge but we start from a very strong
start and finally after many many
debates on trying to gain a degree of
energy independence we are finally
producing gas natural gas a lot of it or
producing much more oil as a matter of
fact we are on the threshold of becoming
the largest energy producer in terms of
natural gas and oil in the world oh
that's a huge difference if you're
looking at your balance sheet on the
asset side because food and fuel any way
you look at it and this were
our basics of foreign policy the people
will fight before they starve and they
may fight if they don't have energy for
their populations so we have at least a
lot going for us but on the other hand
other side of the balance sheet we are
still involved in war and Afghanistan we
have at least terminated war in Iraq of
the war in Iraq clearly started under
considerable controversy each one of us
who talks about these things I really
even bears some responsibility as I do I
was on the Foreign Relations Committee
it was privy really too much of the
intelligence had to cast votes that were
critical at various youngsters in this
situation but the United States had not
been without problems before the 911
attack after all we had fought in this
century-old a century of World War One
World War two a Korean War Vietnam and
so forth nevertheless there was a
certain quiet period in which this
attack of 911 really came out of the
blue to say least maybe almost as
striking as the Pearl Harbor attack that
I heard about on the radio was driving
along as a boy in Indiana I would just
say that at this point there had in
fairness been at least an attack by
United States forces in Afghanistan and
will be felt was an al-qaeda camp so
this was not totally beyond our purview
of our intelligence sources but it was
not a significant attack and we really
didn't know exactly what happened at
that point well we began to find out in
a hurry and before long we were sending
troops to afghanistan beginning a war
that continues in that country even as
we speak this evening Oh in addition to
that we had already been involved in
warfare involving Iraq and its invasion
of Kuwait and I remember very well
debates that went on at that point
then President Bush was asked why are we
in a war and he said well we are
fighting aggression we cannot allow
aggression by a state like Iraq James
Baker may be in a candid moment said oil
now both had something going for them in
terms of those arguments because it led
to our hearings in the Foreign Relations
Committee that reveals we should have
known that her back in the 1930s the
Roosevelt administration had been
dealing with Saudi monarchs and it was
valuable to both sides for the United
States the ideal was that the Saudis
would be responsible for producing the
oil that we needed we didn't have enough
even in those days and we needed a
source of supply that was constant and
certain on the other hand the Saudi
monarchs wanted our assurance that they
were going to stay monarchs that that
regime would as a matter of fact
continue to prevail against all comers
and this was a deal vetta as our Foreign
Relations Committee hearings often
pointed out cost may be about five
hundred million dollars a year over the
years because it meant really constant
deployments and intervention in the
Middle East to keep the Saudi safe and
to keep the oil lanes going both and
this was very critical for our security
well in any event when Kuwait was
invaded the Saudis were not really sure
whether they wanted American troops on
Saudi soil quite a debate there and some
would say the fact we did have troops
there may be for too long led to some
spur to the al-qaeda movement in Saudi
Arabia whether that's the case or not we
did push back the Iraqis but they were
on our minds and when rumors floated
around that they were developing a
nuclear weapon or maybe even were beyond
that point of having one this led then
to a call for the end of Saddam Hussein
and the end of that regime that was
creating this sort of a problem
now as it turned out we all know that
didn't have the weapon at that point but
at the same time I can remember vividly
the military testifying fight apart from
the administration that if we didn't
move at the particular time of year that
we move the weather was really going to
turn very badly for us it would not be
nearly so a propitious the later on and
in essence we went to war as it turned
out he didn't have the weapons but
fairly rapidly we terminated the regime
of Saddam Hussein it began really a sort
of a streak in American foreign policy
which show was expressed again and again
during the recent Arab Spring situation
in the same way that we felt the Iraq
dictator need her to go we felt like
why's that the dictator in Tunisia and
then Libya and then Egypt now in Syria
almost glibly must go and just very
clearly these folks don't belong in a
world and which were a country for
democracy for human rights for rights of
women for development of children and so
forth but in any event he was overthrown
this led to Americans sort of coming to
grips for the first time I believe with
how many Shiites and how many Sunnis
there are in the world how many there
were in Iraq in particular and after you
got through the sunni-shiite business
how did the Kurds fit into this with oil
the oil in the North out without a
particular relationship either of the
two major groups oh it was our feeling
that essentially the way out of this was
democracy the development of
institutions that would lead to
elections with eadral Parliament and a
prime minister or some executive
legislative responsibilities and
furthermore this became a goal of at
least a portion of American foreign
policy leaders that this would set a
model of democracy in an area that
didn't have very much democracy the idea
was that democracies don't attack
other democracies if you had a Middle
East set up of democracies finally we
might come to an end to this racial
warfare and to all the rivalries that
had been there well it was an important
dream but never beyond that because at
this time we finally got to a stage
where it looked as if an election might
be held we saw the Sunnis in Anbar and
elsewhere were they were still very
active today coming out of the woodwork
and we managed to arrive at least some
accommodations we had the so-called
surge I remember being called to the
White House President personally wanted
to talk to John Warner and me because he
thought we might be a little bit
skittish about the surge I guess but
anyway we went through the surge and
felt we were winning the war and if L
had an election Maliki did not have a
majority the Shiite who finally has
prevailed but the Sunnis became a part
of a coalition likewise the Kurds but as
a part of all of that ultimately Maliki
said to us that you've got to get out of
Iraq we wanted to stay with at least
10,000 15,000 troops remotely much more
remotely than the troops we've had in
Europe since World War two or in Asia
since that period but the Iraqis said no
and so a great expense we withdrew
everybody out of Iraq our we could have
predicted what occurred but nevertheless
it has been very sad witness and
presently as you note last year over
eight thousand iraqis killed each other
and we're on track to least have that
many casualties this year between the
CITS and students they really have not
come down into a situation in which they
are able to get along and the Kurds have
gone their own way and some are involved
with Syrian Kurds and others and the
Turks up in another part of the area so
that after all of the sacrifice of
Americans both in terms of blood and
treasure we have a very very difficult
predicament
Oh on this is force prelude to my
thoughts about Afghanistan before the
election of barack obama i can move a
very bitter colloquy between the
leadership in the House and the Senate
Foreign Relations Committee people about
the Iraq and Afghanistan situation
essentially Democrats harpooned
Republicans my saying Iraq is your war
your republican war and we want out of
it as fast as we can we've got polls
that show that eighty-five percent of
the american public want to get out of
there tomorrow Afghanistan is the world
we should have been in this is our war
and so forth many events Barack Obama
won he had a meeting i remember vividly
at the White House invited about the
same people who have been involved in
the previous conversation and he said I
have good news for you we are going to
withdraw from from iraq by the end of
this calendar year well this enraged is
Democratic supporters who said now that
wasn't the election was about not a year
from now out now that's the republican
war and so forth well the president
maintained at least his grace and we
left after a year but we left there was
nobody out there with Afghanistan the
ward that Democrats at least and that
meeting wanted to continue to fight why
we went on and on and on and now we're
at a point in which the debate is how
many troops we get in Afghanistan stay
after 2014 we've been trying to get the
president of the country to agree he has
not said he would said he wants to have
another election on the country before
we ever get to that point it's a
situation in which as people talk to the
Afghan villages and brea others they say
don't leave us because first of all were
likely to have more conflict if not with
the Taliban al-qaeda or other
associated terrorists we're likely to
have problems in our own situation
you've helped to set up schools for
children you have made possible rights
for women in this country they found
that all this is going to go and so as a
result a good number of Americans see we
really can't turn our backs on things
that are so important to us democracy
human rights women's rights children's
rights but at the same time polling once
again in the country shows between 75
and 85 percent of the american people
want out they're tired of the whole
business a feel that the government
there is unsympathetic and as a result
that we've done our part so this is a
liability on that side of the situation
now in addition to that predicament we
have of course a whole host of
situations going out of the Arab Spring
business Sunnis and the Shiites going to
war using not only Syria of whether
Assad must go or not as a battleground
to fight out the desires of the Saudis
or the Iranians on one side with the
Iraqis now sort of sighting at least the
Shiite part with the Iranians others in
the UAE and and so forth helping out on
Saudi side a situation in which right
now John Kerry I saw in the place today
still hopes that there's going to be the
beginnings of a peace conference but he
hopes some of the of the Syrians will
attend but has not really clear who and
and exactly where that thing might go
and and furthermore even if they all
attended whether they can come to a
truce whether everybody agrees they will
lay down their arms if you're a more
volatile a Shiite and you've come out to
fight in Syria you're not really
interested in the peace
conference there are so many people from
other countries coming in and out of
Syria one of one of the problems that
Europeans now tell us they're facing as
a sum of the same sort of thing that we
saw sadly enough see at the Boston
Marathon you have people that are from
countries whether it be France Germany
others who are caught up with a
religious fervor that comes from a
Muslim temple and they go out and fight
and and they believe really is their
destiny to die and maybe to do so
suicidally well some do that but some
come back to their countries each of
these countries is now facing how do you
sort of screen out folks who have been
heading out to Syria recently and wonder
really what's ahead and each of these
cases well these are problems that we
have been facing as a country great
argument in our own country as to
whether the president's policy with
regard to non-intervention aside from
humanitarian services occasional arms on
the periphery the various groups the
diplomatic conferences we now have very
very tough row to hoe to say the least
and unlikely to go away very rapidly i
would say in addition to that that we
still have the problems with Iran and
North Korea and nuclear weapons are
those negotiations and with the Iranians
may work out in my own view is I've
given is that we ought to give diplomacy
a chance but as all of you have read
there are at least a majority of members
in the United States Senate presently
want to pass additional sanctions
against Iran to try to make life more
difficult for the Iranians and certainly
make it more difficult for John Kerry or
anybody else who are trying to bring
about diplomacy out there president
claimed he'd veto all of this but the
number of Democrats adding to the almost
unanimous feeling of Republicans who may
be just trying to cause some trouble for
the president make this a very ver
a tenuous a predicament to say the least
and so we sort of keep our fingers
crossed we thought regard to all of that
I mentioned these all is a background
for the fact that even if we brought
solutions to this there are now
increasingly in countries throughout
northern Africa as well as the Middle
East terrorist groups were all familiar
with al-qaeda and al-shabaab and others
but others that really come out of
religious feelings out of all sorts of
reasons and this has led to some some
challenges that each one of you may have
views about for example as opposed to
having troops on the ground as we have
had in Iraq and Afghanistan some have
suggested our better bet is to use
intelligence services intelligence
cooperation with other countries and
then to send drones and to do the
attacking as opposed to having
battalions of troops of that our best
bet really is to isolate the terrorist
leadership or various folks that
intervene here because there are so many
countries so much space and yet usually
people who are willing to work with our
intelligence sources to do this now one
difficulty the Pakistanis point this out
vividly all the time in arguments is the
lot of the drones have been hitting in
Pakistan is to this violates our
sovereignty you've never declared war
precisely this but then that's the
predicament of our new foreign policy
there isn't a nation-state situation you
have individual persons floating back
and forth who are of menace to various
countries including our own so in any
event we are developing more and more
drone capability but we can anticipate
others are going to also in the future
we're not we will not have a monopoly on
this particular situation even as we're
thinking about drones and intelligence
we ought to be thinking much more in our
foreign policy about cyber warfare
cyber warfare is beyond my ability to
describe as I can barely use my iPhone
successfully but nevertheless there are
people in this world who can describe at
least how you would shut down a banking
system or even if you didn't shut down
the whole system you might come to New
Haven and shut down all the telephones
and all of the emergency situations in
the hospitals and lots of other services
and create enormous problems and
suffering for people quite apart from a
comprehensive national attack we're
going to be on the third of a threshold
of trying to come to grips given this
electronic age and the new communication
devices that we have as to how powerful
they are I was in a conference recently
that the think-tank CS is produced in
preparation for what used to be called a
ver kunda conference in Munich each year
the security conference there and one of
the great preoccupations of course in
Munich is Angela Merkel feeling or
telephone has been tapped and the
difficulties of our negotiations with
the Germans in which we bring up about
everything in the world and they bring
up on the Merkel's telephone the
question is what is the scope of NSA
what is the scope of commercial agencies
around the world who will have gone well
beyond NSA in terms of their
sophistication NSA barely taps in to how
well google functions are various others
as a matter of fact what should be in
our country the criteria for so-called
privacy quite apart from the privacy for
Angela and the world out there and that
but this is the world in which we live
in which even if we don't shut down
people system we are going to be accused
of reading all of their mail and of
looking at their telephone conversations
a very different predicament to say the
least I would say in addition to that we
will face as I mentioned earlier
the food and fuel crisis again and again
the case can be made that one of the
greatest predicaments that Mubarak had
in Egypt was not the Muslim Brotherhood
but it was the problem of feeding people
back in the hustings thousands of people
tens of thousands of people who were
prepared to fight and die before they
serve and this again and again is going
to be the case around the world how do
we get into food production and then
very complicated case all by itself how
do we develop more and more of a world
trade system without barriers barriers
for food barriers for energy it's very
trying right now for our government
attempting to formulate new trade
negotiations with Europe and with Asia
and not knowing whether the Congress has
any spirit whatever to deal with this
particular thing this year even if it's
rather crucial in the world to move
these goods and services for our own
benefit for our own jobs and prosperity
as well as for the rest of the world but
in the critical issues of food and fuel
absolutely vital in terms of our foreign
policy and security so these are very
very important issues and finally I
mention a subject that it would be
consuming us all for a long while
climate change I don't ask for anybody
to adopt any particular doctrine with
regard to this I was reminded as I flew
into the New Haven Airport here today
saw how close to the the waters are a
number of houses there of articles that
run rampant in our papers almost weekly
of the fact that whatever reason could
be produced by nature itself quite apart
from man the waters are rising those
people are going to be in jeopardy if
you have at least a little bit of bad
weather a lot of jeopardy we have
already had a little bit of this in the
United States i've gone to conferences
in which i was told as a public official
it was my responsibility whether you
believe in climate change or not to map
out for your own home
on your own home state how you going to
rescue people how the hospital is going
to work how physically the roads are
going to work in other words this is
going to happen and it's going to happen
in many places not just the Seacoast but
where you have rivers or lakes or so
forth in this country quite apart from
parts of the world even more vulnerable
and which is widely predicted they
already are facing this we don't know
what the melting of ice and the Arctic
means it could be a warfare as people
tried and back to claim all the rights
underneath to see that they've always
felt that they had no fixed boundaries
there in the United States I'm willing
to get into treaty negotiations and
phone terms of law of the sea but these
these are on the horizon leaving aside
war in Iraq or Afghanistan these are
questions that aren't nation states
versus nation states but their states of
the world in which we live of nature
food and fuel and so forth that that
really we can meet but we are going to
need extraordinary cooperation within
our country as well as very very active
diplomacy in the world and I applaud our
Secretary of State John Kerry with time
our work and our Vice President Joe
Biden who was out there all of the time
our son Hagel is now secretary these
were all comrades for years sitting
together to end for the hearings or a
learning experience and Foreign
Relations Committee I think they're
doing a good job and I would just say
that I applaud the attempts of the Obama
administration to invigorate
international trade very vital for us
and for everybody else given all the
barriers to all the protectionist
elements that are not just in this
country but all over the world and
finally we get back to the fact that we
really do need to continue to promote
our ideals of democracy of human rights
of women's rights the rights of children
it may not be that we are going to be
able to stay and simply reorganize Iraq
or reorganize f be honest
but nevertheless and through exchanges
of students and exchanges of adults
businesspeople of diplomats of everybody
so we get to know each other same
revelations I had when I first went
abroad I'm sure repeated again and again
by people of all ages who move we have
some idea of how big this rule is how
dangerous how complex these are people
then with whom we can deal that we have
a much better audience in terms of our
own ideals and our own progress so let
me conclude by saying that we start with
a balance sheet in which we have very
very strong assets a lot going for us to
say the least we have a balance sheet of
liabilities or potential dangers that is
very significant not overwhelming but
ones that are going to require very
active intelligent forceful American
advocacy and staying power I'm excited
about those possibilities we are not in
a World War thank goodness we're not a
mutually assured destruction we are in a
situation in which we could move if we
are inclined to do so and I applaud this
Center for all the encouragement it
gives to people young and old to think
about the world to think as human beings
about each other to act in humane and
active intelligent ways I thank you so
much for the honor of giving me this
opportunity thank
senator lugar can take a couple of
questions before we would move to the
reception so my question is how the US
foreign policy and gap to meet an
emergency I know so a pretty good yet
China which will I believe that we are
making progress in our conversations
with Chinese leadership as well as with
those who are not in leadership let me
point out that even a short time ago
when a Chinese leader came to Washington
and I had a chance ask who is
commander-in-chief in your country and
he sort of smiled wanly and said well
the Communist Party didn't say he was
now we're moving toward a situation I
believe in China in which the
presidential the chief executive officer
Billy is going to be in much better
control of the military now some people
find this to be alarming they would say
if China is about the same stage as
Japan was about 10 or 20 years before a
Pearl Harbor but but others would say
that as a matter of fact China is
aggressive with regard to the South
China Sea and various other push and
pull maneuvers but finally we are having
more conversations in our military and
there's we're having more conversations
at all levels with Chinese leadership
thank goodness more American business
people are in China actually producing
goods and services and vice versa the
number of students coming here to Yale
as well as in the end University and
what happened China enormous thank
goodness so at least not necessarily be
persuaded by what we're doing but in by
being in the culture in other words we
have lots of opportunities to let
diplomacy work and I'm confident that
we're going to take advantage of those
but we need
talk about it frequently so that there
are not miscalculations and that the
growth of China and all the people of
China toward more fuel more food more
opportunity moves right along with our
own and we keep at least a situation of
transparency with each other number of
folks as the Iraq war was winding down
it felt that there shouldn't be a
unified government but that it should be
divided into a Sunni yeah I heard
provincial kind of a unified basis and
we see with the deterioration of the
single government right now that for
happy that's where it's going anyway
after a period of time and once it look
at Syria of other countries and say
maybe they're doing too and so the
question to you is how do you feel about
abandoning sort of the country style
approach that we have right now that
we've gotta preserve Iraq or preserve
Syria as they're currently set up on the
map and and go to a different viewpoint
of those countries and go back to tribal
or regional aspects of government well
as you remember Vice President Biden who
was in chairman the Foreign Relations
Committee suggested that kind of
division we had public hearings on it I
was it was widely condemned at the time
and maybe at that time it appeared that
we felt the elections are going to
perceive that a coalition could occur
the cooperation with the curves in
particular for the oil and the resources
there was necessary but in any event
you're right that the idea has
reappeared in Syria because it's not
really clear that the ala whites are
going to be able to prevail and continue
to rule as they have with ten percent of
the population is not really clear at
the end of the day whether some of the
boundaries drawn by
Europeans after world wars that define
really where these countries are are
appropriate given the divisions that
have come up subsequent or even were
there then that might not have been
observed and and so I'm not one that's
advocating at this point drawing of
lines I don't have a map from which I
think we could work this out but i think
it's an idea that we have to retain at
least some openness to how pragmatically
boundaries might occur or groups of
people might find each other so that it
is not a question of one group trying to
annihilate the other or subject them to
tyranny only to be overthrown by the
other if they have opportunities and
allies and now with a situation in the
Middle East in which other countries are
coming in to play ground the whole
situation it's simply because they have
very strong religious convictions or for
male have a sense of adventure so this
is seems to be on the table as we get
into the discussions about the future of
Syria in particular on a more political
note after you left the set of your pack
gave lots of money to Republicans were
facing challenges from the right but you
also gave money to Michelle Nunn in
Georgia whose Democrat 70 s daughter I
was wondering if you see any hope for us
moving away from the polarization in the
city and moving back towards the more
moderate candidates like that what I
think we're all prayerful that this may
occur some occasion but I don't see it
happening very soon I think we are still
in for a period of intense partisanship
and in part this is because we have
rearranged our country at various of the
levels we have state legislatures that
have redrawn congressional lines to
create so-called safe districts so that
in essence the battle is in the
primaries not in the general election or
independence or others a might might
make a problem and so again and again
after you do that and then you have
Citizens United case with regard
unlimited political spending much of an
anonymous whether it be club for growth
or freedom works or the Koch brothers or
whoever else we've got tens of millions
of dollars sometimes coming in on a
particular state will find a part what
the people as state are interested in
and influencing the television ads the
circulars all the rest of it this is a
very different period of time in our
political life but it all tends to
reinforce the situation so that members
who are incumbents trying to guard their
their continued ating you know in office
are very much inclined to move very far
right or far left as the case may be
since that's where the decision-making
is likely to occur and then when they
come to Congress and people have
scorecards from each of the different
groups as to how how they behave
themselves they have this problem of
self-preservation so it's a tough time
to be a member of Congress and to look
across the aisle and to try to provide
and that's going to have to happen to
get the two-thirds majorities that are
necessary to overcome betos or to pass
treaties either 1 or the 6 seed overcome
filibusters every day and we're faced
with that problem and type of one more
because ever you just come friend what's
the influence of Yale University in
people at you because you mentioned you
with the mayor media that you invited to
come will not yell advising you you
mentioned you went to Russia is kappa
the children and then you spend the
money so what is the influence of the
accademia in people you were driving in
the menstruation oh it's huge because
somebody really has to provide an
education for us in other words um
somebody who actually knows something
about the various countries we're
talking about from personal experience
or from academic responsibilities or
just from debates that have occurred not
just on campus but through national
associations and so forth a very very
important part of my education at every
point along the way of people that I
called in to try to offer advice
testimonies a nice public testimony we
had when I was chairman constant
hearings in the Foreign Relations
Committee for the benefit of the members
but also for the public for the press
for everybody else to gain at least a
degree of Education and to be referred
to the books of the scholars or their
papers or various other things really
for further reference so this is an
extremely important aspect and I
compliment the melon center again for
providing such a great forum a one that
has such energy and so many people
participating at all ages we come to a
time when I think we can move to the
reception on the penny common room at
second full of love to which everyone is
invited
and we can thank senator lugar for an
amazingly comprehensive analysis of our
international and political scene thank
you very much